you guys hear about the story about this
customer service representative that
starts from the bottom Works its way up
and then becomes the number one customer
service rep in the world becomes a
billionaire this guy becomes a
billionaire and everybody's like how the
hell do you become a billionaire being a
customer service rep insane everyone's
asking about this guy I want to tell you
about him by the way if you get any
value from the video and gets you to
think give it a thumbs up and subscribe
to the channel so let's get right into
it you know who the number one customer
service representative in the world is
that became a billionaire his name is
Elon Musk and let me tell you why he is
the number one customer service
representative in America today do you
realize how many CEOs in America today
are sitting there saying Ilan don't talk
to customers you're embarrassing me I
never engage with customers on Twitter
please don't talk to customers let us
CEOs Who hide in our offices and allow
other people to engage I don't want to
be exposed that I have to do that as
well please don't talk to customers and
Elon is saying so what do you think
about this latest feature on Twitter on
Twitter hey what do you think about on
Tesla if we do this yeah that's not good
I heard about the news with the Tesla
crashing I'm not happy about it hey very
disappointed about what we did here but
we're getting better hey do you guys
like to let me run a poll what do you
think about this we're definitely on top
of it no one engages more with customers
than Elon Musk does by the way let me
bring it on a smaller level so you
understand how the simple concept
applies to everything you do no matter
how big no matter how small you are this
works since
2002 2002
till today I I ran a system because I
read an article about how the
Rockefellers would write notes and all
this other stuff that they had and how
you know Clinton when he ran for office
he wrote 20 000 handwritten notes to
become a President Lincoln was big on
writing letters I'm reading all these
presidents right because presidents you
become a president you're essentially
campaigning musk is campaigning your job
as a salesperson as a entrepreneur you
want to be a manager leader you must be
on a campaign everybody wrote birthday
cards anniversaries everything was about
communication so here's what I did
started off with 10 cards a month
because I only have 10 clients and I
would say hey thank you birthdays are
only once Year anyway so you got 10
clients you got 12 months of other one
birthday in a month maybe you're gonna
have a couple months they're not gonna
have birthdays so I would just send
cards to people and I would call how you
doing how's everything this last week we
did a Black Friday and then we did a
cyber monday on Black Friday I made a
call and FaceTiming people for five
hours surprise FaceTime people are
hanging up on me I would call them I
would say hey I'm calling you from
America can express your money to us and
I'm pulling pranks on them they're
cracking up we're going back and forth
They're laughing wife starts crying a
husband naked in the shower picking up
the phone we're having this incredible
conversation together the name of the
game to make it to the top of your field
no matter what business you're in is
customer service customer experience
customer engagement
and most people when they start making a
little bit of money and becoming too
famous they don't want to talk to lower
level employees they don't want to talk
to customers they don't want to deal
with them they say ah talking to a
customer that's not my job that's
somebody else's job and a guy who's
worth nearly 300 billion dollars says
you don't call the customers because
you're too big too cool to make these
calls don't worry I will and you know
who is exposing everybody not just
Fortune 500 CEOs not just Fortune 5000
CEOs anybody that's in business and in
sales he's shown the world that your
number one job as a CEO is to do
customer service so question back to you
how good of a job are you doing with
customer service yourself are you making
those calls are you talking to them if
you're not this is the perfect season to
start calling your customers now and
just engaging with them no matter what
it may be if you got value from this
video give it a thumbs up and subscribe
to the channel and I did a video a few
years ago titled the difference between
customer service and customer experience
if you've never seen it before click
here to watch that video having said
that have a great week everybody take
care bye-bye